what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host on Saucon very excited to
be talking about innovation ecosystems
and startups we have Tristan Cromer
joining us on the show are you Kristin
hi Allen thanks for coming on nice to be
here really appreciate it I'm super
excited for our conversation for those
who don't know Tristan's background
Tristan is founder an innovation coach
at chromatic which is lean coaching and
innovation ecosystem design you can find
links in the bio below to chromatic calm
as well as his blog LinkedIn and Twitter
profiles
all right Tristan let's start things off
by asking you one of our favorite
questions were your thoughts on the
direction of our world
general nervousness combined with
optimism yeah things are kind of strange
right now very disruptive from a number
of friends from business to political to
personal one would almost say and I have
a lot of hope for the future but there
are definitely a lot of things that
should be making a lot of people nervous
and hopefully rightly so so that we can
take action and do something about them
we've pretty confident that the species
will rise to the challenge I'm confident
that we will try and rise to the
challenge I am not necessarily confident
that we will succeed I think we will
survive but if they're they're
definitely a lot of tipping points
coming forward from everything from
global warming to what have you and the
question is whether where is that
tipping point have we already passed it
just the fact that we have you know
farmers in Kansas suddenly recognizing
that global warming is taking place
means that maybe we've already passed
that tipping point but I certainly hope
not I were sitting here in Silicon
Valley technology moves very fast a lot
of technologies on some really nice X
mental curves like solar panels so it
certainly lends to optimism that we can
actually recover from our own mistakes
and make something really great out of
this crisis and turn it into a good
opportunity but we'll see what do you
think the main skill for adults and
children to embody in order to make sure
that we win that wisdom race ooh that's
an interesting one I am going to have to
give the perhaps more fluffy answer and
say emotional intelligence knowledge of
the self mm-hm
that would probably be my number one
like you can have any amount of
intellectual capacity but if you're not
kind of aware of your own blind spots I
think it's extremely hard to apply yeah
yeah know thyself some of the most yeah
oh gee wisdom they haven't said like
every religion right yeah yeah exactly
first know yourself and then then help
each other yeah have you ever taken like
a first responder course may be acting
the day yeah I I took a emergency first
responder course for as part of rescue
dive training and one of the first
things they teach you is like don't go
run and help somebody where you stop for
a moment look around because if somebody
you just got hit by a car the last thing
you want to do is run out into the
middle of the street and get hit by a
different car then like then you've just
doubled the problem you haven't fixed
anything so the first thing is make sure
you know what's going on make sure
you're aware of your surroundings and
then go try help and I think that
certainly applies to the basic so it's
like well first of all figure out your
own issues and then go and try and help
everyone else yeah yeah
love that yeah it's also this new age of
people talking about cleaning their own
room or clearing their own channels and
anchoring their own divine first and
then being able to go out and help the
world yeah yeah I'm I'm not so far in
that direction as to say you know just
just meditate every day and that'll fix
the planet I don't think that that's
gonna work I don't go to the moments of
silence that the Oscars are gonna do
anything but but first we have to be
aware of our own issues and then who
were you growing up that got you
interested in innovation ecosystems and
startups I mean that's probably a
question you have to ask somebody other
than a I don't know I've always been
very interested in more creative things
in general I was a musician for 10 years
I played a lot of music growing up I was
always involved in what I would consider
creative activities be that from from
music or playing Dungeons & Dragons was
a very big thing that's kind of a
creative form of storytelling so I think
kind of wandering into the more Silicon
Valley technology and innovation area
would kind of fit very nicely into into
all of those things Silicon Valley and
rock and roll are very similar in many
many many ways from this kind of
idolatry of like the the hero or the
rock star they're even called rock stars
in Silicon Valley to what it takes to
work creatively between between
engineers and business people and
designers and the drummer and the guitar
player and the bass player they're very
very similar dynamics in terms of how
teams form how teams create and how
teams actually get that creation out
into the market in some sense get people
listening to that music at people using
that application or that technology the
dynamics are incredibly similar and
so coming here felt very much like
coming home to some degree so we then
are have these gifts that we can bring
forth into the world and then when we
pair ourselves with others it can the
combinatorics of that are very has a lot
of potential to be incredible but we
have to understand what forces were sort
of combining together what our value
systems are between founders between
these different musicians that are a
part of the band because then that's
gonna impact the music that we produce
and the amount of people that care about
that music the way that that music can
hopefully help uplift our culture and
our world raise the consciousness of it
solve the problems of it yeah I I'm not
sure if I would use the word aware
because there's a certain amount of
randomness that is inherent in any
creative process and it just just stick
a whole bunch of people in the room and
see what happens
sometimes there's not a whole lot of
self-awareness going on there but there
is as you said that that combination
effect right like what are the different
permutations that these people can
create with their different ideas and
their different backgrounds I think the
key that you just brought out is having
different backgrounds and not just
having like a a clone of the same person
three times like that's very very
important in music like having people
with creative differences but not so
different that they can't get along and
create something at all but those
creative differences are very important
in music and they're certainly very
important in in business and technology
yeah ooh yuck the creative differences
are the way that the the worldviews can
then help augment each other to maximize
creativity yeah it's it's the ability to
realize that
but it was our reading today in the news
some some person decided to combine a I
can't remember Fein a single layer of
graphing with clothing mm-hmm to create
a mosquito proof clothing damn yeah
there's just something that I'm sure
many of us would be very very happy
about mosquitoes are not a net benefit
in the world but who decided to do that
what person who is studying
metamaterials or these amazing new new
materials that are coming out and just
decided to check to see if mosquitoes
could penetrate that with their little
fur businesses mm-hmm
that's a really cool thought it was
probably just some random person who
hated mosquitoes or just went on
vacation and said like hey I wonder if
this will work maybe you didn't have any
background in that material whatsoever
but just past the idea long and those
ideas spontaneously colliding can create
something new and interesting so
combining seemingly disparate fields
into new innovations yeah critical
critical I wonder yeah what the future
would be like of wearing a single layer
of graphene on clothing and how that
would make us feel and you know all that
type of stuff yeah there's a lot of
things I was reading about was whether
or not it was breathable and sound and
so forth that type of stuff
okay what about chromatic so you started
this eight years ago and what have you
been doing with chromatic teach us about
how you're approaching organizations
startups corporations what principles
you're helping them with in terms of
innovation ecosystems
okay so chromatic yeah chromatic was
started eight years ago now it's kind of
thrown into a slightly larger company
and a network of partners around the
world and what we essentially do is we
work with either directly with
innovation teams just to help them get
their concepts out the door and test it
in into reality as fast as possible or
we work one level up with the
organization
or the country that the government level
to figure out how to support those teams
better like what are the systemic
obstacles that either startups or
corporate innovation teams are facing
that every time they try and get out the
door the legal department comes at them
and says we'll stop like we don't want
you to go outside that's risky that's
dangerous to us not to pick on the legal
department too much but it's just one
example of sort of a systemic obstacle
that might stop the innovation in a
company or even in a country and we try
and figure out how to remove those
obstacles does that make sense yes so
then the give us more of the obstacles
cuz the legal team isn't one of these
obstacles sometimes they are not
physical sometimes they can be
absolutely wonderful and a big help
there are lots of different obstacles
from from procedural obstacles like fact
that would be the legal team but there
are more kind of hard softer and fuzzier
obstacles that are a little bit harder
to quantify but still possible like fear
like fear is a really important obstacle
for innovation that the fear of failure
the fear of showing your idea to
somebody else and having them shoot you
down tell them that you're not
interested and you think it's stupid
fear of success which is kind of a
strange for some for some people to
happen but some people are actually
afraid that they own oh if I say this
idea out loud I might actually have more
work to do now I'm actually gonna have
to do it I didn't want to do that I
wanted somebody else to do that idea so
there are things like that other
obstacles can just be the money side of
things what I would call air support or
or the obstacle would be the dinosaur
right so that would be an investor if
you're a startup who says that's a
wonderful idea I'm gonna give you
$50,000 and I'm gonna take 60% of your
comedy because perhaps my background is
in real estate and that sounds like a
good idea to me but if you're in the
technology industry you know that those
are terrible terrible deal terms in fact
that's going to prevent you from ever
being able to raise capital basically an
investor who wants
to judge your idea based on a four or
five year business plan that is
essentially a fiction it's just numbers
on a paper that have no evidence that
hold no feedback from the market these
are the type of investors that by virtue
of putting their money in the wrong
spots can actually stiffle innovation
because they're only willing to invest
in things that are sure bets instead of
the risky things that can really produce
those exponential transformations that
we want from technology
mm-hmm yeah those are critical key
points so then let's talk about then the
way that this helps make product teams
go fast so when these obstacles aren't
in the way how does this make people go
fast well so the basic idea of okay so
there's the difference between an
invention and innovation
okay so invention is about creating
something new and innovation is more
about having a sustainable business
model that is going to repeatedly take
that invention to the market and and
create something that I can survive and
sustain over time so I can I can create
whatever it is whether it's an awesome
new tea mug that keeps my tea warm
mm-hmm whatever it is but if I don't
have a way to get that to market I just
have one tea cup right I want something
that's really gonna transform the
industry or transform life we know how
to do invention pretty well hey R&D is
very well funded all in the globe like
people know how to do that we know that
you can stick a few very smart people in
the garage and you'll get new stuff but
taking that to the market has changed a
lot in the past certainly since I've
lived to Silicon Valley definitely in
the past five years or so because of
lean startup and
the movin really started by Steve Blank
and then Eric Ries and the basic idea
there is that whatever you create
whatever you think is wonderful and
amazing the only way to prove that is a
real sustainable innovation is to take
it to the market as fast as possible do
not spend three years trying to perfect
your idea mmm or going back to music to
perfect your one song but to actually
just go out play it on a street corner
if you need to go to a club play an open
mic and test it out and see if people
applaud mm-hm and get that feedback as
rapidly as possible so you can iterate
so you can make changes so you can
improve on the color or the shape you
use your interface whatever it is and
make something that people truly truly
want and are willing to to pay for
something that brings value into the
world and if you don't have that
feedback loop coming from the actual
market you are stuck in this land of
invention rather than getting to the
real innovation where where change
actually happens mmm so it's so critical
then to do things like take our idea and
go immediately as quickly as possible
and get feedback from the market and
there's got to be some sort of a balance
though between me going into like
recluse mode to make sure that my idea
is ready for market receptivity but also
in market feedback but also the
importance of actually getting that
feedback and going and doing that versus
just trying to perfect it yeah and and
there there is some degree of balance
there and it depends on what domain that
you're in okay like if you are doing
something that requires a very large
degree of Technology which we're we we
don't necessarily possess right now like
if you're doing lab grown beef that's
still a pretty new area there's a lot of
technological hurdles in order to get
that to the market that's something
where you would certainly want to not
necessarily be recluse but you need to
go into a lab and figure that out right
yeah but if you are doing something
where
the technology is not necessarily the
issue it's really whether or not people
want that product at all like whether
people want this new pop song or this
new sound that you're creating well
they're most of the risk is in the
market it's not on the technology we
know how to play guitar we know how to
play bass you know I play drums we don't
have to do songs that's not an issue
it's a question of whether or not
anybody wants the thing and if that's
the type of product you're creating you
better go to the market fast because
that's the risky risky thing and more
and more today technology is not the
issue we can do amazing things with
technology particularly in web
technology I mean we can build whatever
you want but whether or not anybody
wants the thing whether or not it's
going to deliver value to really
understand that you have to go and try
it out with it customer so then yeah so
there's definitely depends on the field
then I agree that it was a great example
on on basically anything that requires
like the the safety maybe of or like you
know like the Food and Drug like
administration strings like that or like
if you're trying to innovate on maybe
like some sort of like a a transit
vehicle or what-have-you just so that
it's at least it doesn't kill people yes
we don't want to put anybody on me like
beta version of 0.1 of the Hyperloop and
see them plow it six hundred miles an
hour into a wall that would be very very
bad like there is substantial technical
risk there but I like your examples of
like a poem or a pop song or maybe a
chapter of a book or these types of
things our food or a new drink like a
lot of these things there's not that
much technical risk there's maybe some
and you would balance between you know
the the Rd aspect of making sure that
you can technically produce it but the
market aspect is is much more dominant
these days because even if you produce
something that's technically perfect
maybe nobody still wants it if you
produce something which people wore if
you know what people want eventually you
will figure out the technical solution
is
the question of time right but if you
can't get the market it doesn't matter
what you can create technically yeah yep
interesting so that again there's
another massive balance between doing
your technical due diligence and making
a product or service just exceptional
and also being able to capture the
market so this is kind of also the
importance of having exceptional sales
people that know how to build
relationships and close deals but also
having excellent engineers and designers
yeah what about the greatest obstacles
for startups and then the greatest
obstacles for corporations what are
those and so they're they're pretty
similar
we just typically tend to use different
words for them okay and so for a right
so so every startup exists in a certain
environment right so here in Silicon
Valley it's very very easy for me to go
out the door I can go to a meet-up I can
go to hackers and founders here in
Silicon Valley and I can meet a whole
bunch of people I can meet a technical
person that I need for my team I can
meet a designer and I can create a team
very very easily if we were sitting in
let's say Tokyo that might be slightly
more challenging okay maybe being the
environment that ecosystem doesn't exist
in in quite as a Bunce it's not for the
odds it's not as abundant it's not as
supportive in the environment if I fail
as an entrepreneur in Silicon Valley
that's actually a good thing like that
that's a bullet point for my resume that
I have a good failure that I tried to do
something entrepreneurial I went out it
didn't work but now I've had that
experience and I'm better for it whereas
if you are a failed entrepreneur in
Buenos Aires they might look at that
like you are a failure as a person right
that you're not worth hiring in our our
company because you
so that's sort of that sort of potential
fear impact from failure like that's
that's an obstacle in that environment
that I would classify under fear mm-hmm
right and that exists for startups but
that also exists inside corporations
there's everybody who works in a large
corporation knows somebody who's been in
an innovation project that didn't work
mm-hm got fired because of that mmm and
that causes failure that causes fear
that causes a level of fear where you
might not even want to attempt an
innovation project whereas someplace
like Amazon that's a very different
corporate environment like they
encourage you to fail they we don't in
fact be disappointed there's there's a
giant list of failures from the fire
phone or I can't remember
giant lists of failures for Amazon that
you can you can go to google and I don't
work at Amazon but as far as observation
can can can get me it seems to be fine
like it seems to be a good environment
where you can try out new ideas and if
it doesn't work that's okay as long as
you learn from them yeah and there seems
to also be this like critical process
when you have that new idea or
innovation that if you follow a process
that is robust that is a lean that has
Design Thinking principles embedded in
it that's really your true calling in
your true purpose in the world then
maybe you have a higher propensity of
success with that idea maybe I mean what
I would say is that I I have not seen
any data that says the the kind of lean
as opposed to the more waterfall or
build it and they will come approach has
any particular higher chance of success
but lean gives you more chances more
kind of swings it back so yeah
interesting right so if my approach is
just the the Kevin Costner Field of
Dreams approach like I'll build this
crazy thing and then the cut
we'll just show up and I take a year to
build my product and at the end of that
year I'm out of money
that means I have one chance to succeed
so yeah maybe I have a 100 chance so
I've got my one percent chance it's not
very great but maybe I succeed maybe I
don't but it with a lean approach you
would take that one year and you would
test something out on day one you would
put up a landing page with your concept
you would explain it to people you would
go out and talk to human beings and you
would see if they respond if they react
if they're interested if they want a
sign of surveillance that's just so
important it's just everyone talks about
ideas and it's just such a simple thing
to just set up your landing page the
center let go and talk to people about
your idea and try and funnel a couple
people into the first product or service
or session and just go and do and create
a meaning will come from that process
right so if you do that 365 days of that
year maybe each chance is only 1% but if
you keep on changing your idea based on
feedback you've got at least 365 chances
to get something started mm-hmm so
that's where I think the real power of
lean and design thinking come into play
that it basically just allows you to get
feedback and have more opportunities to
get it right 365 permutations versus one
young mutation and also that kind of
speaks to our show in a sense because we
don't do one show per year we do 365
shows per year ok and it makes it so
that we get a lot of feedback and a lot
of practice and a lot of diverse content
for people to pick up and try and work
with and get inspired or engaged by yeah
absolutely yeah so it mm-hmm
was just tough because of the whole
signal-to-noise ratio thing too because
if you are just trying to run 365
different experiments for business ideas
that
maybe like 340 of them will just be like
just noise out in the universe afterward
but you know only 25 of them will
actually have signal and people will be
interested in them so this is a very
tough thing to to balance and as
understanding how much noise we create
sometimes like some of our interviews
have content in them that is just it's
me just being a bad interlocutor you
know or it's just you know in in this
sense then I don't do the best job
possible at unleashing the guests
fullest potential out from them and so
in a sense it's like well that content
could be made better yeah and so you
wonder about signal-to-noise ratios you
wonder about these types of things that
come from that I mean if that's true
that's it's really two different things
that you're talking about there right
like the the first thing you mentioned
was well what if you run 365 experiments
and 25 are good how do you separate
those or how to even choose between the
first 25 which is more of a question of
hey look don't run 365 experiments at
the same time mm-hmm you know as soon as
you get signal on one DoubleDown mm-hmm
so hopefully you're not going around 350
yeah and you run like something you run
maybe 30 and then you double down on the
31st because it gave signal exactly you
got something double down on that okay
you're making small pivots you're not
doing completely different ideas but the
second thing you mentioned is just kind
of running clean experiments like what
you're talking about in terms of doing
365 interviews a year with different
people with different environments
different variables maybe the sound is
not good maybe there's bad weather today
and I show up and I'm in a bad mood or
something crazy like that you can't
control for all those variables that is
a problem in startups and technology but
at least for a lot of the projects which
I'm involved with you can control a lot
of the variables it's something like a
website or technology or a new food
product where you can control a lot of
the variable
you can even if we were doing a new type
of cake
I like cake it's my birthday a couple
days ago thank you very much but if I
was creating a new type of cake you know
I can control the environment I can put
it in my test kitchen I'm going to
create the same batch of cake each time
and use the same ingredients and I'm
gonna make one raspberry flavor and one
strawberry flavor and I can I can AV
test those by changing just one variable
and controlling everything else mm-hmm
whereas what you're talking about with
the podcast as I said it's very
difficult because you have at the very
least two very human very variable
variables yes yes okay that was great I
like that I like the analogy of the
baking a cake yeah because these are def
this is not raspberries and strawberries
this is you know complex human and
complex human yes this is this is
comparing you know I want to say sushi
to souvlaki or something I don't know
how to compare those two tastes at all I
didn't make any sense why were sushi to
a baseball game Hey yeah yeah what is
the difference between agile versus Lean
Startup versus Design Thinking the
difference is more in perspective like
they're all facets of the same thing all
of them relate to this basic premise of
we don't know something so let's try
something see if it works and if doesn't
work let's try something else it's the
basic principle behind all of them right
yeah but agile comes from a very it was
created by technologists front by
engineers so who wrote the agile
manifesto and so kind of where they
start that iterative loop is slightly
different from where a business person
might start that loop like more like
Lean Startup right like Eric Ries is an
engineer so the way he coined that
iterative loop
build measure learn mm-hmm and he starts
it with built as eric is an engineer so
that's his first inclination is let me
try building something and I'm gonna
measure it see if it works and then I'll
hopefully learn something from that
experience and know what to build next
yes where as a business person might
start with or defining a KPI and say
well wait a minute let me know do
something similar but let me go
backwards here what am I actually what
am I trying to impact like what is the
metric that I'm trying to change and now
based on that metric well how would I
how would I learn that like what sort of
experiment can I do
mm-hmm that's gonna change that what
what information do I need and now let
me perhaps decide what to build and and
then see if it impacts that metric so
they're really saying more like a
measure learn build measure learn build
measure needle designers have the
similar Luke called think make check and
they they're designer so they start with
think don't start with bake they start
with think so it's really just a
question of perspective designers like
to start with kind of that creative
aspect engineers tend to typically start
with building something cuz these people
typically start with measuring something
first but they're all essentially saying
the same thing which is let's recognize
that we do not know exactly what the
customer wants we don't know exactly how
to solve this particular problem let's
try something out see if it works
doesn't work do something else yeah you
know in a sense it also reminds me very
much so of publishing content on the
channel and seeing what sticks what
inspires people what gets them engaged
versus what does not and having that
closed-loop feedback of comments and
conversations I mean yeah that's the
same look we have as children right like
it's something I think we've forgotten
as we get older like we try and stand up
we push up we immediately fall over and
we figure out a different way to do it
we tried it with both hands we try it
with one hand we try it
holding on to perhaps a larger person's
pant leg as we go but we we iterate and
we experiment
and sometimes we've kind of forgotten
that I think again partly at a fear of
rejection you're the trauma of failure
but nowadays you almost can't start a
business without without getting
something into the market and see if it
works
nobody's willing to fund the next Segway
anymore so when you're going into the
different startups and corporations and
how do you identify their innovation
ecosystems how do you find the right
people to talk to how do you teach them
about these hands-on experiences that
they can do in order to become more
effective well there's there's two real
approaches I mean there's one that that
I personally favor that's just to you
know roll up our sleeves and start
working if I'm able to immediately get
engaged with a team start working with
them I'm gonna see very very quickly
what what wall they run into whether
that's again like fear we were talking
about or silo in the organization that
prevents us from accessing perhaps the
Salesforce or the customers I'll find
that out very quickly by simply
embedding myself in that team and
working with them at least on a weekly
if not more often basis so that's a very
very quick way to understand at least at
a small level what are the typical
obstacles that the teams are facing I
can do that with two or three teams I'll
have a very good sense very quickly of
what the environment is and which
obstacles are the biggest issue today
the other method is of course just to go
and talk to people most people know what
the issues in their company are and
they'll tell you very very quickly oh
it's it's my boss doesn't know how to
fund innovation the sales team won't
talk to us we don't have any engineers
in our company the bureaucracy is too
heavy the regulation is to have you mean
you afraid of poisoning people as you
said or having some catastrophic
technical failure they'll tell you
pretty quickly
Wow you know just tell you straight up
what the obstacles are and if you can
have honest conversations with you oh
yeah which is pretty easy if you're
doing it kind of not with the CEO
looking over your shoulder they will
tell you relatively quickly
the only kind of caveat I'd put there is
that there is a certain amount of
finger-pointing that goes on and that
typically isn't the biggest issue hmm
there's something even deeper than that
well it's not necessarily deeper it's
just perhaps of greater impact like for
one large consumer gets corporation we
did two workshops at some point on Lean
Startup and Design Thinking and one was
a workshop entirely of the project
managers and product managers and one
was of the executive team and we did the
same exercise in both rooms and we
simply asked everybody you know write
down on a series of sticky notes what is
the biggest obstacle to innovation in
your company mm-hmm and in the product
management group they all basically said
the same thing or it was one of the
biggest biggest clusters that really
wrote down what it was fear the
management is afraid to invest in
innovation and they don't support it
like they're afraid they'll get blamed
and in the other room which was
happening a few hundred yards away they
did the same exercise and the management
said that the product managers were
afraid of failure mm-hmm that they were
the ones that were unwilling to to risk
anything they were too risk-averse and
so that's not to say that either of them
were wrong but that was a really easy
issue to solve at least for that group
because we just put them in the same
room and have them present their results
to each other and they realized that oh
we thought you were the ones that were
afraid oh no so just just recognizing
that and bringing that to the surface to
some degree helps helped immediately
didn't solve it it across the
organization but is immediately a little
bit better what do they do then when
they both know that information about
each other how do you then move forward
from there
well heifer Wow hopefully from there you
can immediately just start funding the
teams that's that's the main thing that
sort of cultural norm of being
risk-averse of being afraid is is
definitely a long haul change you really
have have to have I think a lot of
committed people particularly on the
executive side who are willing to be
transparent about failure that's one of
the biggest things you can do is just be
transparent when something succeeds and
fails and not punish the people involved
actually congratulate them for
successfully invalidating a product idea
but it generally it's best to start at
the top and have you know even the CEO
if you can get them come out and say hey
look the last mistake I made was a
billion dollar mistake so guess what man
if you screw up on this product and lose
$10,000 I don't care it's not a big deal
don't worry about it you're not gonna
lose your job you won't be punished I'd
rather you take the risk and fail then
not take the risk like the risk of not
innovating these bar greater than the
risk of failure I love though on the
risk of not innovating is greater than
the risk of failure yeah yeah it's a
good one so yeah that's one of the first
things that we try and do what's the the
government's that are getting involved
in innovation now I mean almost what
government isn't getting involved in
innovation I mean this this happens I
think sichting cyclically to some degree
there's always especially when economies
start slowing down people start thinking
about how do they encourage innovation
some forward-thinking governments are do
try and get ahead of the curve and think
about how can we encourage more
entrepreneurship in our in our in our
ecosystem you look at the government of
Estonia I think is extremely
forward-thinking
I like Estonia I'm not trying to say
anything bad about Estonia but Estonia
is not a land of great natural resources
that they can exploit it's it's largely
swamp it's a very small country it's not
a huge powerhouse it doesn't have
millions and or billions of people like
in China so they have to be really
effective in terms of attracting
entrepreneurial talent making sure the
companies stay in Estonia and they've
done a really good job in terms of
creating electronic citizenship making
it very easy to start a company they're
getting even fast fast internet
encouraging accelerators funding
startups these are all activities that
they've undertaken to try and spur the
next level of innovation and you see
even countries like the United Arab
Emirates it's obviously a very oil based
economy they know that they are at high
risk of disruption right government of
Norway as well which we work with oil
based economy they know that eventually
oil is finished I don't know exactly
when that's gonna happen but it will
happen eventually so they need to
diversify and create different
industries and the way to do that is to
encourage innovation so you know United
Arab Emirates a lot of those oil based
countries are trying to diversify their
economy into a knowledge economy where
technology can take the place of oil and
be their next source of growth Norway's
done a fantastic job at encouraging
these clusters of excellence in oncology
maritime technology yeah they're very
very supportive and they put a lot of
active effort into innovation Norway
including these innovation outposts in
Singapore and here in Silicon Valley and
in New York so almost every government
has something along these lines and it's
typically closely related to the
economic development department this
also speaks highly to the need for
diversification of one's portfolio in a
country yeah this speaks highly to
need to innovate quickly as an entire
country with the limited amount of maybe
resources or people or whatever you have
at that time is how do you fund
unleashing the gifts and the creativity
of the people of that country and
especially moving into the digital
technology age there's also a part of
that is like how do you handle things
both spiritually and geopolitically when
there's so much progress happening in
neuro technology or biotechnology or all
the AI and robotics but also there's
this there's this the lack of our own
spiritual actualization like we're still
in kindergarten ourselves we don't know
how to collaborate across borders we
still have multibillion-dollar military
budgets happening so like how do how do
you see the geopolitical climate mixing
together with the innovation economy
that's very interesting one I mean it's
it feels like you're you're kind of
talking about the system that's in play
right because all the things you're
talking about are not necessarily
contradictory or opposed to one another
right like I don't know what the ideal
like military budget should be right but
the military the space space exploration
has propelled technology forward
radically like you can look at the
number of patents and materials that
came out of the space program and it's
kind of mind-boggling the degree that
which they they pushed out an eventually
the kind of commercialized and generated
a lot of value out in the world but
there is sometimes this kind of negative
feedback loop where industries become so
entrenched that they've become
protective and they start trying to
vent innovation in a particular area I
like that the system starts feeding upon
itself there you're talking about I
forget what it's called a technical term
for the military-industrial complex
right where if you are kind of creating
barriers to entry where your plane that
you're inventing you've successfully
distributed the parts to that plane in
every single state so that senators
can't vote against you ever defunding
that program and that money is then as a
consequence being taken away from basic
science from R&D technology that might
that might create the the next Space
Station in the next the next basic
science that might propel Internet
technology or quantum computing or
whatever you want to have out of it if
that if that entrenched industry is
taking money away from areas that are
truly exploding in growth that's going
to be a big problem mhm and I'm honestly
I'm not familiar with how the budgets
are allocated in the US or other
countries but certainly you can see that
I we lost a huge amount of pace in the
United States compared to China in
supercomputing in quantum technologies
in the past years I think we're still
leading but not by as much as we should
be if we'd been investing our money
wisely and what about the idea of
measuring success when you're so small
this is innovation accounting from the
country perspective or a team
perspective both ladies in the smallest
country is not that small so it's
relatively a if you have enough of a
sample size
so maybe let me answer that in a very
weird weird fashion the the issue with
the issue with measuring things when
you're kind of very early on I I think a
lot of the times come down to our biases
human beings to perceive linear
equations when a lot of things are
exponential it's very hard for us to
understand what an exponential curve
means and I don't know how apocryphal
this is but rate there's a story about
Ray Kurzweil that you know the human
genome project right so the Human Genome
Project was a ten-year project to map
the human genome hat five years into
that project they were one percent
finished so there was big uproar
everybody's like this is a huge waste of
money they're never gonna be finished
this looks like a total disaster they're
only one percent finished and they are
halfway into the project and five years
into the ten-year project and allegedly
rate first of all looked at this and
said whoa sounds like they're right on
track mm-hmm because he knew that the
technology was the the efficacy of the
technology was doubling every year so 1%
was gonna become 2% 2% was gonna become
4% 4% becomes 8% 816 and all of a sudden
you go from 1% to a hundred percent in
five years and they were done on time
mm-hm but it's hard for us to see that
you know we see 1% done after five years
and we say well after ten years is gonna
be 2% done so when you're very very
early on you have to understand how to
measure things and what to measure and
also just understand the basic trendline
of whether or not it is a linear
function or an exponential function
because something like lab-grown meat
seems like a really long way off unless
it's on an exponential curve in which
case we'll see it very very quickly even
the the plant plant beef the
that coming out with the impossible
burger then that went very very quickly
from something that was kind of a
mediocre substitute to something which a
lot of people just rave about now and
that's one of those technologies that we
were talking about at the beginning
makes me a little bit more optimistic in
terms of the future because moving from
a beef economy to a plant based economy
is definitely better for the environment
and almost any measure possible so if
you can get plant-based or even lab
ground beef that is going to save the
consumer desire that's gonna be hugely
better for our planet and those
technologies are proceeding at an angle
randomly fast rate so just understanding
like the difference between those two
equations immediately helps you start
evaluating your technology and
understanding what you need to strive
towards and what you need to measure
yeah that's a great way to put it I like
that I like the linear versus
exponential understanding for for that
idea of innovation accounting it's also
just really hard to measure in general
when you are like a young like media
company or when you're a young just
brick-and-mortar business how to measure
your success along the way super hard
but a lot of it's almost like are you
waking up every morning and feeling
really passionate about what you do are
you able to sustain your innovation do
not only your own energy but also being
able to you know financially support
yourself to these types of questions I
mean that that example that you just
gave right there is I think a really
nice example of those two two concepts
right and and how you might measure them
differently like if you're a brick and
mortar business like that that's a
linear system right because there's only
so many people that are going to walk
past your store and they're not going to
be doubling every other week
mmm-hmm like your honor versus a
distribution of media content or
software or whatever
exactly right like that's something
where it's much easier to to get
exponential growth by by going viral
which is not to say that having a
brick-and-mortar store is bad not at all
but you're gonna measure those two
things very very differently you've got
to be aware of linearity versus
exponential attea
yeah because if if you're starting a
media a media company or whatever a
website and you have ten customers and
one of them is very very happy you might
think like I only have one customer I
might as well call it a day this sucks
but if you say well wait a minute
actually my conversion rate there is 10
percent 1 out of 10 so if I just
increase my distribution I'm gonna have
and I can get a hundred people coming
through I'll have 10 sales so my
conversion rate is not too bad actually
it's okay I'm ignoring all the
statistics and margin of error of that
but at least if I look at the conversion
rate as opposed to the raw numbers I'm
probably okay I can afford to lose money
today because if I just increased my
distribution I'm eventually going to be
able to pay for this website and then
this technology or as if you're a brick
and mortar store only 10 people walk
past your store today there's only gonna
be 10 people walking past your store
tomorrow so I need to focus on I need to
have a much higher conversion rate there
to survive mm-hmm yep this is the pretty
simplifies to exams yep I like the focus
on what you're gonna focus on is very
very different in one case you're going
to focus on just wow I can just focus on
distribution another case you really
have to nail and
customer that's coming through the door
yeah you know and do things like
prioritize word-of-mouth as well for
people that have a good time at your
brick-and-mortar and then ask them for
referrals and try and get more people
through online funnels to know about who
you are this type of stuff perhaps then
you're leveraging some of that more
exponential delivery I asked you for
Yelp reviews and Europe
whatever your opentable score and so on
and so forth that's one definitely one
way to do it what are some of the buzz
words that you hear versus the reality I
just didn't startups in general yeah I
mean so much as a buzz word lean
startups a buzz word Design Thinking is
a buzzword agile a buzz word I mean
there's a whole crop of buzz words which
is just the technology which people
think if I insert the word artificial
intelligence plus blockchain into my
pitch as a startup I'm gonna get more
funding which is sadly true in some
cases and that's just irritating because
people are using blockchain for things
that doesn't really even apply it
doesn't make any difference but
what-what I guess I guess where
buzzwords come into play more with what
I do is when people are kind of doing
the more cargo cult thing they're saying
well I I do agile we do our daily
stand-ups every day and we have a
retrospective meeting where we all give
two thumbs up at the end of the weekend
and that's agile you know we we follow
the scrum methodology but they're not
actually doing at they're not actually
agile they're doing the the rituals but
they're not absorbing any of the
benefits they don't understand why
they're doing them they're doing their
stand-ups like a status report this is
what I'm doing today as opposed to
saying this is what I'm doing and this
is how it might affect you and here's
where I'm stuck and I need help
those are the things that those are the
conversations that should be happening
in a daily stand-up very quickly
yeah
right but if it just becomes a status
report where your or your rattling off
numbers and nobody's really paying
attention to each other and people are
just doing the ritual then I think that
it's it's very counterproductive and
then you'd really just absorb the
buzzwords without absorbing any of the
impact yeah so that's that's my pet
peeve and then in terms of the emotional
aspect to these journeys for you kind of
hinted at this a little bit where people
feel like they are maybe pointing
fingers at each other across companies
and saying that it's their fear it's
their fear of inability to innovate but
there's also just this it's like this
hero or heroines journey that people go
through in order to really suffer and
then to just be like I need to innovate
like I need to change my behavior I need
to make this idea happen I need to take
a burden on my back I need to go forth
and bring something of value into the
world so tell us about how you've been
dealing with that understanding the
emotional journeys that people go
through and helping them go through the
processes of healing and bringing forth
their ideas yeah I mean the emotional
challenge I think of entrepreneurship is
this ability to simultaneously be
extremely passionate and extremely
optimistic about the change that you
want to make the the value that you want
to bring into the world but not being
overconfident or zealous so the delicate
balance between humility and confidence
yeah and and I guess I know in a true
hero's journey there's always that
moment of doubt right but I think the
difference between reality and perhaps
the the movie version is that if you're
gonna go out and test your idea every
day you're gonna get hammered down a lot
and if you become kind of overly
confident that your idea is the best one
you stopped testing because why would
you test if you if you believe your idea
is perfect then there's no reason to go
out and test it with the market yeah
but you can't just be doubtful at the
same time you can't just sit there and
be like well I don't know about anything
so let me let me test everything let me
a be test the color of this couch let me
make sure that I have the right amount
of salt in my eggs in one you can't AV
test everything right because a you will
be paralyzed and B startups are
incredibly hard it is vicious to God and
get rejected every day and make it a
deliberate practice of rejection and if
you don't have a certain level of
confidence and faith that what that you
will eventually get there then you are
not going to have the mental and
emotional fortitude to get through those
hard times oh I don't know I know I I
know some people who perhaps won't admit
it but I personally do not know of any
start-up founder who is not at some
point just been broken down in tears
because they thought that they'd
absolutely wasted their time in their
life that all of their employees really
fired like everybody if your startup
survives long enough you will have that
moment and you will have that moment
where you're under the table just going
like what have I done
so if you don't have the resilience and
the emotional well-being to get through
that and the support system I think we
should which everybody needs to get
through that and have some people who
can hopefully a co-founder who can hold
you up when you're feeling down and you
can hold them up when they're feeling
down it's going to be very very
difficult to to get through things and
and that still holds true if you if
you're working in a corporation or even
if you're working as a you know a cog in
the government wheel you're still going
to have the same thing if you want to
truly make a change you're gonna have to
put up with a lot
terrible terrible times and you better
be able to stick it through otherwise
you you won't you won't breakthrough
I'm curious about what your relationship
has been like with a higher power a
source God all that is creation what has
been your relationship with that higher
power and what relationship do you see
other entrepreneurs and innovators have
with a higher power that enables them to
be more effective
first of all I could probably answer
more easily than a second one it's
actually not that I'm thinking about it
I know we mentioned this before the
cameras started rolling but I don't
actually talk about kind of religion or
spirituality with a lot of founders I
know that a lot of founders a
particularly are in Silicon Valley had
something along those lines but nobody
really talks about it there's very much
this sort of Western philosophy of like
it is my my will to power right I would
love to see places like Silicon Valley
Shenzhen Tel Aviv all these like in like
central startup drivers of the world to
just focus on spirituality and
philosophy as they focus on AI and my 10
always thinks because that's really how
I think we will have a higher propensity
for winning the wisdom races by
combining those yeah yeah that's
interesting because there is a this may
be a very Silicon Valley specific thing
but there is this kind of demarcation
where everybody goes to yoga class and
as their spirituality moment and goes
off on their Zen retreat and then we're
at the office right now right now we're
working there there's not as much
combination of those things as as one
would think
given this environment and that could
actually help maximize efficacy in that
environment if we did that better
maybe I mean there are a lot of I mean
there are certainly almost
technology-enabled spirituality now
right
so there's the butt of the comm app or
whatever II have which is like yeah
again sometimes yours into maybe that
ritual over over the meaning maybe
people are using the comm app but
they're just thinking about their PML
statement or meditating maybe too much
monkey mind but yeah yeah there's not as
much open discussion about those topics
as one would like so let's do your
relationship first with the higher power
and then we'll do others I mean
personally most people would call me
either Taoist or a type F monist and
it's mostly the same ish thing familiar
with Taoist what's a type F it's like as
very specific Mon si classifying as
monus's like so my philosophy is that
there is only one thing in the universe
there is not like a spirit and matter
it's not only matter or that's not only
spirit it's just there's one thing it
doesn't matter if you want to call it
spirit or where a physical substance
doesn't matter it's all the same stuff
mm-hmm
what's the class-f side of it it's just
I think he had ABCD yeah either no it
was a long time ago I read that oh okay
okay
no it was just a classification system
hasn't heard of the morones
classification system before so I asked
okay
it's basically it's basically the idea
that there is no fundamental difference
between me sitting here and this couch
the grasshopper out there almost one all
is essentially one everything is
interrelated I'm not saying that your
couch has a consciousness and debating
philosophers in itself but it is a less
organized less organized unit of that
like it has a different level of
consciousness so so to speak so
essentially I'm more of a Taoist like I
I don't think that there's any sort of a
higher power that is sitting around
giving instructions I don't think that
there is any
I don't think that there's a big big
book which we all have to tally or
ledgering and get into heaven or get
into hell at the end of the day but I am
very much under the belief that we
everything is hyper-connected I can't
control what you do or what is happening
on Alpha Centauri with my thoughts or
anything like that but I acknowledge
that everything is very hyperlinked and
we have to be aware of that and there's
there's a very flimsy the definition of
self is very flimsy mm-hmm like where I
stop and this couch starts and and you
start it's all very malleable I have
millions of organisms living inside me
right now as bacteria that impact me on
on a regular basis and mm-hmm that
effect on my my free will and my ability
to to act his is very profound yeah so
the self is a very arbitrary construct
where do you see the the this gift of of
us breaking away from that oneness to
adventure in these bodies do you feel
like that's just an experience in earth
school that we're going through I'm not
100% sure I know you mean by truth
school like that you came here with a
specific mission or goal to learn
specific things and that you are taking
that back to the central source after
you pass and personally not so much I
mean look why I basically look at the
universes and as the universe is
constantly just trying to understand
itself right it's creating itself and
it's trying to understand itself at the
same time and we're just one expression
out of many of that I don't think we're
gonna kind of deliver our earthly hard
drives back into the to the mothership
and get an answer sometime but this is
just an expression of creation and
and I'm very pragmatic I don't worry
about it too much do you feel like we're
all paint strokes or notes being played
in the grand symphony of creation
there's a I wish I could remember
there's a wonderful poem about quanta
about string theory that kind of reminds
me of what he just said yeah I mean in a
way we are all just expressions of the
thing right so if everything is all
interconnected there is essentially just
one thing right like that's that note is
impart and we're all just expressions of
that thing kind of looking back at
ourselves trying to understand what the
hell is going on it's a part of the
whole trying to understand the whole
which is a fundamental contradiction
that that we will never get over it's
fun it's awesome it's intriguing but at
the end of the day Here I am in my body
trying to figure out what to do in my
life and what value I can add and how I
can make everybody else a little bit
happier at the end of the day and that's
what I try to focus on and then where do
you think that the role of freewill
versus predetermination exists we have
to believe in free will we have no
choice in the matter why it's pretty
much hardwired into us explain that more
Ivan is literally just like a you can
there's a wonderful story that that
probably everybody who listens to you
would enjoy if they liked this topic
called by Ted Chang I think about the
kind of a predictor machine it's like a
machine that uses quantum fluctuations
it's a sci-fi story it's a little
machine that basically can predict when
you're gonna push the button and will
blink a light immediately before you
push the button yes okay and the concept
behind this this machine is that you can
never trick it it's perfect right so
every time you see the light you push
the button
even though pushing the button is the
thing that causes the light
retroactively way and so this machine in
theory proves that you have no free will
because every time you see the light you
are forced to push the button
essentially and in the story it kind of
drives some people insane if they become
apathetic and they just sit around and
start ruling and honestly I don't think
that's the way it works so within that
story there's both that we now have
neural reading technology that can sense
when the thought originates and then
lights up the the button before we even
press it but then there's also this
component of where does the thought even
originate from in the first place yeah
there's a whole kind of the theory of
the epi phenomenal mind right which so I
think the experiment you're referring to
is that you know somebody throws a ball
or something and I move to catch it but
the brain region responsible for moving
the arm activates after I catch it right
but I feel as if I was the one who moved
the hand and so the theory there is that
that consciousness thing is actually
irrelevant
it's interesting it's kind of unprovable
to some degree and honestly to some
degree I think it's irrelevant right
like they're fun things to ponder like I
can ponder the consciousness of an
octopus where it's its intelligence
actually seems to be distributed through
its entire body like the limbs behave
quite independently in some regards but
they're they're coordinated somehow it's
fascinating but at the end of the day
isn't it more interesting and more
important to focus on like what I what
can I create what can i what can I do in
this world today that's gonna make
things a little bit better how can I
know myself a little bit more I mean
does it matter if my consciousness is at
the phenomenal or not if I have free
will great if I don't have free will
well then I don't have free will about
whether or not I think I have free will
so what difference does it actually make
in my day-to-day action have you ever
known anybody who was 100% convinced
that they didn't have free will that all
of a sudden just seized up and stopped
functioning so that wouldn't yeah that
would not be healthy for human behavior
but at the same time there's a truly
profound understanding of that oneness
that is if what role freewill plays in
that oneness is just really interesting
it's interesting but some of those
questions like wind up in do you know
this guy I think his name was Berkeley
or he's a philosopher that fought like
the whole world was an illusion right
but there was only the mind and the
liveness is like this to some degree as
well I think he thought that there was
just you and you were kind of separated
from everything else and you were just
kind of watching the universe unfold on
a kind of projector like projector like
scream that you were just receiving
sensory impulses essentially but at the
end of the day if you are in this solid
fistic mind and you think that
everything was just senses
if I throw a rock at your head you're
still gonna try and duck so hmm what
does it matter at the end of the day
right isn't it better to focus on the
other people even if they're even if you
think they're an illusion like isn't it
better to focus like aren't you happier
as your own person by not turning
inwards and turning into this kind of
solid bistec creature like isn't it
better to engage with other people you
know and try and do something how about
we ask you this
these bifurcating moments that are on
our life trajectory is really relevant
to our endeavoring into startups or
innovation how do you decide both
personally and seeing entrepreneurs
doing it how do you decide on those
moments where it's like should I pass
for hours going on a nature hike or for
hours on work or should I pass for ours
investing into my child's life outcome
where should I invest four hours into
making money so they can go to a better
school how do you figure out how to act
in those bifurcating moments I mean I
would I would ask what's gonna give me
the biggest payoff in the long run time
I guess I'm more utilitarian in that
aspect right so if I'm trying to solve a
problem and I have an option of cranking
on that problem for four hours or taking
a walk for four hours like you have to
ask yourself would did the walk help you
sometimes getting away from the problem
is the best way to solve it if you're
trying to decide between working on your
startup and having a successful home
life that's probably a more profound
question and going back to do you have
the emotional fortitude to actually
succeed with this startup in the long
haul are you gonna have that emotional
fortitude if you're going through
divorce at the same time mm-hmm
what do you really care about like what
are you building for that's actually
something I think is really interesting
it was quite on your your agenda but I
think a lot of entrepreneurs some
entrepreneurs have a goal of making a
specific change or helping a specific
person and some entrepreneurs just have
this goal of let me make money or let me
be famous
that's probably more popular on these
days right and I I don't fundamentally
have an issue with that - somebody wants
to go and make money and that's their
only goal awesome but it could
definitely [ __ ] with nature it can [ __ ]
with the health of other people it can
yeah there's a lot of issues with that
oh all of those things are true right
but at least internally that person is
being is very self consistent right if
they genuinely say all I want to do is
make money and I don't care what
particular startup idea I can argue with
that person that is generally you will
make more money by helping people then
like giving people cancer mm-hmm I can
do that but fundamentally I can't argue
with that person there they have an
entirely self-consistent logic right but
I do have an issue when it's kind of
like it's an undefined nebulous
never-ending goal like if the goal is to
make money
there's no point at which you succeed
it's always making more money it's
always being more famous like there's no
vision there's no it's also true about
helping people you help one person maybe
you want to help ten if you want to help
one hundred I guess so but if your goal
is to cure Alzheimer's there is an end
state there that you can aspire to
interesting if your goal is to eradicate
poverty there is an end state and
there's a happy marriage between ending
Alzheimer's and making some money along
the
to be able to fuel maybe other creative
endeavors a fuel your family's success
and health absolutely that you can
actually live long enough to keep doing
and I would hope that if you cure
Alzheimer's you are gonna make some
money yeah but I I get irritated with
it's it's the people who try and do who
try and pretend they're doing one thing
when they're actually doing the other
that really bother me a lot it's it's
when somebody claims to have this
aspirational like I want to put it I
want to change things for the better but
they're actually just trying to make
more money that I think is very
disingenuous so total counter productive
to their own efforts and being sniffed
out by the rest of society really I mean
you're not gonna get away with it what
about the overall meaning of creation
what is the purpose of this for us to
all creatively express ourselves to
maximize consciousness to make the next
cycle of creation happen what is the
point of this that's the point of
creation I mean that's that gets a bit
amorphous I mean eventually mmm you know
eventually none of its gonna matter
we're all gonna be
the Sun will get it to a certain size
and the earth will be on honestly I
think existence is its own good
like it's better to exist them to not
exist and I have a delight in seeing new
things I see a delight in in every new
combination and even the painful stuff
in my life I have enjoyed in retrospect
I am glad to have experienced something
bad then experienced nothing at all like
the worst times in my life that I look
back on are the ones that are just
absolutely dull and gray and bland and
nothing happened like that to me is is
horrible that's purgatory for me damn so
so I always think that the there's no
greater reason for it then it is it is
creation itself like the act of creation
itself the existence of the universe is
all isn't it of itself its own good
and combining two random things and
getting something that's just a little
bit different than either of them
together where 1+1 somehow miraculously
equals 3 is a wonderful wonderful
wonderful thing and something that we
can all strive for and it is the only
way that we're going to eradicate
poverty is the only way that we're going
to fix climate change is by not doing
more of the same stuff yeah that's not
going to work
yeah so I'm I don't have any great
philosophical reason to it other than I
think that everybody enjoys that I think
it's better for everybody when we try
and be more creative and try and apply
our talents to to maximize happiness for
everybody maximize value for everyone
rather than just capture some of it for
ourselves yes yes so that that is the
creative that is the creative spark that
that I was trying to pursue is just to
create more value not just capture but
myself create more value than you
capture maybe one of the purposes
defecation yeah what do you think is
truth just epistemological II like
definitions of truth
sure
I mean I I think for the purposes of my
life in my work I guess there's there's
there's kind of the big truth in the
little truth right so there's there's
what happened
and then there's communicating that in a
way that's understandable unusable so
this is poet now I'm gonna forget his
name I think it was Jerry Costanza or
something like that you know Jim Daniels
told me this quote he said the truth is
no excuse for a bad poem and I really
liked that him and he he he brought that
up when when somebody in my poetry
classes is like 20 24 years ago
something like that he brought it up
when somebody had this really nice poem
that just ended really badly and
everybody in class kind of had the same
comment that it was just a beautiful
poem but it's the ending was an absolute
flop and his is responsible that's what
happened I said well the truth is no
excuse for a bad poem there is a certain
point of which sometimes in order to
convey what you're really trying to
convey the emotion in this case in the
poem you might need to stretch the facts
a little I'm not in general a fan of
stretching the facts in general but
sometimes you need to tell a good story
to get a point across it's probably not
what I'm doing with this particular
story but mm-hmm
sometimes you need to leave out certain
details sometimes there is an art to
successful hyperbole that that better
communicates or makes the truth more
usable that's interesting in a very
stupid example I always tell people
never ever ever ever do surveys
never they're terrible why because
99.999% of the time entrepreneurs suck
at writing surveys they're terrible at
them they tend to write really bad
questions like will you buy this product
how much will you pay for it will you
pay $20 for that those questions are
always the answers to those questions
are always lies
people always answer them very poorly
I've run that survey
I ran personally a survey where I threw
220 people and I said would you buy this
automated system for non-disclosure
agreements sixty-six percent of people
said yes would you pay $20 for that 63
percent of people said yes I put up the
landing page through a hundred and
twenty some odd people to it and I had
exactly zero people purchased that
product
yeah those surveys are terrible there is
one out of you know a thousand
entrepreneurs who can actually do
surveys surveys are perfectly good tools
but if I tell anybody that they're gonna
go do a survey they always think they're
the point zero zero zero zero zero one
percent you can actually write surveys
so I try never to say that we got to
true I like it you get the surveys from
truth cuz that's that's funny
sometimes I have to fable a little to
get to the truth that's that was an
interesting point about which details do
you incorporate or leave out in story to
communicate the truth more efficacious
way that's so interesting yeah it's
interesting when you even see movies
like Chernobyl you know it's they did a
pretty good job it apparently a lot of
details but some things are clearly made
up right a lot of the characters are
shoved together they might have one
actor who's serving multiple roles in
the stories because they don't have the
budget for the cast or it just makes it
would make a eight hour documentary into
a 24 hour documentary it's just a choice
like are they conveying the essence of
what was important or are they not and
then what would you say is love what I
say is love I always like to think of
love as an action not something that
happens to you and it's not like you
just fell in love and there it was I was
in love I felt out of love I think
that's stupid sorry yeah hi anybody I
think that's utterly ridiculous I think
what was the effort that
on day to day basis so if you love your
job you better put in the effort on a
day-to-day basis if you love your wife
or you love your husband you better put
in the effort on a day-to-day basis and
and every time that you are not putting
in that effort you are not in love you
are you're not you're not being loving
do you love you how much do you love
yourself put in that effort on a day to
day basis sure absolutely
take care your health sleep well take
care of yourself yeah take a few minutes
take a breath
whatever you need to do yeah yeah that's
a good point
I like that I like that that I should
love and then what about it's like
attention paying attention paying
attention what is the relationship
between good and evil and what how are
they at play on the planet you're
probably asking the wrong person on this
one because who like for my philosophy
of good and evil or not our human
constructs right there they're human
constructs okay tell us one well if you
didn't they're not creations of God Wow
I mean four of the oneness are from the
unity the creation well whatever it is
of course they're creations of that
because everything is a creation of
whatever that thing you look at is so
everything is the creation of the thing
that's actually a very abstract when you
talk about it like that
no I mean it's a human construct these
are human perceptions if there were no
humans on this planet there would be no
good and evil at least not on this
planet so good and evil are relative to
our experience on this planet yeah but
there there are certainly I think there
are certain Maxim's like I try and
behave by utilitarianism or some form of
Kant's categorical imperative there are
some kind of rules that we can put in
place that make us happier and more
healthy as of individual human beings in
that society but I I am more of a fan of
judging people on their own self
consistency than anything else I love
that yeah self consistency is so
critical
how how often do you actually take that
breath instead of react to something how
often do you actually eat well or sleep
well or exercise or you show love to
other humans always such things how
consistent are you with that yeah just
do you practice what you what you put in
preach and I cannot give you a logical
argument versus one moral system or the
other fact there's plenty of plenty of
literature on why but that's impossible
if you if anybody wants to Google
Doodles good O's incompleteness their
own yeah go for it but if somebody's
saying that that you know to take a
really to take a very 80s example right
so if you're in an evangelical preacher
who says that homosexuality is a very
bad thing and then you go to a motel and
you check in and you have homosexual set
sex that person I can say is a bad
person
that is a hypocrite so so that I have a
very severe problem with but everything
else I can only judge people on there at
least internal logics self-consistency
do you think we're in a simulation it
doesn't really matter to me I mean if
you think everything is the same stuff
that it does not matter if that if you
want to it's like I can only tell the
difference between mind and matter if
there is mind and matter yeah because
you're essentially comparing one to the
other so if you think there is only mind
and then we're all just spiritual beings
you're uttering a nonsensical sentence
because you have to have matter to
compare mine too and what's the
difference hey you're saying there's
stuff there's nothing else to compare it
to so there's just stuff if you just
think everything is physical and there's
no such thing as spirituality and
there's no such thing as mind and gotta
yada-yada you're still just saying that
there's stuff and that stuff interacts
you're basically saying the same thing
okay so people who are kind of entirely
physical Objectivist
forget the term and people who are like
Berkeley and think there's only
perception they're essentially just
saying the same thing they're using
different words for this stuff all right
so if you want to say that everything is
a simulation
okay sure a simulation of what it's a
simulation of itself mmm like until the
point where somebody shuts off the
computer and we wake up like yeah no
reason the matrix we say oh wait a
minute there's this whole other step
there's this whole other realm of
existence and it doesn't make any
difference if we're all existing as a
computer simulation and it's kind of a
closed box and we can't interact with
that other plane then it makes
absolutely no difference to my life
sometimes it feels like everything is
source and other times it feels like
there are things outside of source and
it's kind of an interesting it's an
interesting thing last question
shoot what is the most beautiful thing
in the world
ooh that's a very good question
um I mean my mind is going immediately
to whale sharks because I just loved
whale sharks and I just went scuba
diving but if I wasn't just making a
thing I would just say patience I'm
gonna go with patience my by patience
I think if you're patient enough all the
beautiful things come from patients if
you don't have any patients you are
never gonna have the patience to sit and
wait for the whale shark to come by and
swim by you you're never gonna have the
patience to stick through the hard churn
of entrepreneurship and build something
amazing if you don't have the patience
you're never gonna get through that
first argument with your with your
partner and really achieve a mutual
understanding and support that builds a
great relationship I mean if you don't
have that patience like what are you
really gonna get even the five-year-old
has to be a little bit patient for
dessert and suffer through the asparagus
in order to get here so so I'll I'll go
with patience because it's necessary for
everything else and it has its own
reward what was yours
I love that answer that was such a good
one you gave so many great examples of
patients being super important and
especially in the instant gratification
economy we live in right now to have
patience and to know that to bring your
gifts forth through all of the tests of
faith through all the challenges earn
accolades and experience points along
the way and be in love with that journey
and then the result that that is gonna
have so much more actualization for you
Tristan this has been so much fun I've
had it very cool I've had a blast
talking to you thank you very much for
coming on No thank you for having me and
thank you even if we don't get to it now
you're gonna have to tell me what your
most beautiful thing was after this
beautiful thing is probably source
source the source yeah probably source
they have the fact that there is this
experience is just gorgeous it's pretty
fascinating yeah yeah it's so
fascinating and hopefully we'll
understand the ultimate nature of it
soon better thank you thank you for
coming on thank you for having me thanks
everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it we'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below on the
episode let us know what you're thinking
have more conversations with your
friends your fan
coworkers people online about innovation
ecosystems and about startups and about
bringing our maximal creativity forth
and how to do that best through the
processes of that Tristan was teaching
us throughout the episode also check out
the links in the bio below - chromatic
calm also Tristan's blog LinkedIn
profile and Twitter profile check those
out support the artists the
entrepreneurs the spiritual leaders the
organizations around the world that you
believe and support them help them grow
our links to simulation are below to our
patreon or cryptocurrency or PayPal link
also you can design Colmer to get paid
all those links are below and go and
build the future everyone manifest your
dreams into the world we love you very
much thank you for tuning in and we will
see you soon